what are your passions in life David
what do you what do you really love okay
okay I love to play tennis as a matter
of fact I try to Go Pro when I was 16.
but it's it was it was really
complicated yeah um I mean I played with
the best players here in Colombia and
they destroyed me so
well I gave up on that dream really fast
that's okay that's I mean it's it's good
that you found out then I pursued uh you
know professional football for way too
long before I realized I was no good at
it well into my late 30s I kept putting
on the uniform yeah I put on the uniform
and videotape myself in the uniform uh
eating a bowl of oatmeal and then I
would send that around to all the top
teams
but eventually that I had to learn I had
to learn
so uh yeah what do you okay so you like
tennis I like tennis
um I also like movies I like TV shows
movies and as a matter of fact my
brother uh started uh um like
cinematography is it like is that a is
that that's it yeah so he he studied
that here in Colombia
and he'd try to look for a job in that
uh in that thing but he didn't didn't
find it so he had to travel he left
Colombia and now he's currently living
in California oh well yes there's much
more of that kind of work here in
California so yeah so he's trying to
make him he's trying to make movies over
there I don't know if you guys have
heard about him his name is uh James
Cameron um
hey I'm going to pay you a hundred
dollars to stop making jokes
I don't know what's real with you
anymore you're a shape-shifter one
minute you're a city planner you're
doing uh valuable work for the
government but then you're running the
front desk at some cheesy motel in Ohio
taking bribes uh you're all over the map
you're a tennis star or are you who
knows I don't know who you are teach me
if you can yeah exactly and I also play
the piano
concert by the way what's your favorite
kind of music yeah I listen to
Everything I mean I can listen to
reggaeton but I can also listen to heavy
metal death metal oh are you like death
metal so that that that kind of ring
what's your favorite what's your what
are your favorite bands your favorite
death metal bands
death metal bands well I like
um well I wouldn't say Slipknot is a
death metal band oh Slipknot they used
to come on my show regularly I I like
those guys really yeah yeah they were
they were terrific and they put on a
great show but they're just regular
metal they're not death metal yeah
they're like they're like power metal
yeah I mean death metal Dr Acula it's a
death metal band oh I see what they're
doing there Dr Acula yeah yeah yeah I
see it I'm just piecing it together now
but I see what's happening let me see
there yeah and there's their other band
is Frank middle initial n Stein and
Stein
that's Disney
yeah orthopedic surgeon Frank and Stein
ladies and gentlemen put your hands
together for orthopedic surgeon Frank
middle initial and Stein two three four
oh
[Music]
there is no nothing in the future
do you have a new favorite death metal
artist David
defeat come on that was pretty good oh
well well you have to go a little bit
down like this Eduardo
yeah I want to try and do this this is a
new death metal band called doctor
orthopedic surgeon Frank and Stein
I can do it in post if you will yeah
we'll do it in post
yeah
that sounds amazing
and that's a ballad that was great
that's a acoustic battle
wow uh so you like your your you like
your death metal do you do mosh pits
yeah like do you go to concerts and do
you do mosh pits I used to not anymore
be honest I haven't I haven't been in
the mosh pit in like 10 years yeah
they've changed
his husband is big on mosh pits oh okay
well yeah and so is I'm Matt Matt
O'Brien your head writer likes to mash
it up a nephew that I had to hire oh
okay yeah well pretty good they uh they
yeah they like to mash it up mashing is
but apparently there's you know you're
not supposed to I don't think it's mosh
moshing I think it's pitting oh I think
there's like super big vernacular that
goes with it okay wow yeah yeah well
David I noticed that you wandered off oh
no
I was just trying to charge my computer
Electronics
these two I'm sorry we had a good thing
on mosh pitch and then suddenly we're
talking about all these people they
don't know
uh and wow what an incredible soccer
sack anyway I'm stuck in a hell of my
own making David